ladies and gentlemen welcome to the tim
dillon show we are here thank you
everybody for watching the special and
your
kind words trended on netflix for uh
about a week maybe still trending don't
know one of the top
search things on that platform we really
appreciate that as well as you know tom
segura and joe rogan having me on to
uh
hang out promote that with them had fun
discussions with
both of those gentlemen and christina p
we did a crazy live stream at your mom's
house and then we did joe
the next day while we were down in texas
and now we are back
um
here in los angeles and um
uh really excited a lot of people really
uh
feedback is very positive so we're happy
about that and
you know it's uh you know it's good to
to have it out there and done and then
you know we are moving on
uh to uh other things to many other
things
um
books and films and all kinds of stuff
that is
not
in the immediate future but hopefully in
the not too distant future we are
working on a lot of stuff
um
uh there's a um
i sent this article to ben this was
really strange and uh
you know usually when people sue i
always go like you know do you really
need to sue because we're such a
litigious
country every billboard is like sue them
there was a billboard when i was growing
up
my dad used to pass on the highway it
was called 1-800 sue them
um and that was the billboard and it was
about uh
you know
your ability to sue anyone for any
reason at all
that's the type of country that
you know we have we have a country where
the legal system
you know basically exists as a uh you
know a place for personal vendettas
for get rich quick schemes
um as a way to arbitrate
any and all
uh disagreements
but then there are things where you go
okay i get it
i get it now whether you're a fan of
lawsuits or not to handle problems
there are certain stories where i go oh
i could see that
i could see a lawsuit there
that makes sense to me
black mom sues la unified
which i believe is a school district
over a cotton picking project at
elementary school
yep
this is gonna be one of the lawsuits
that i can understand
a black parent filed a civil rights
lawsuit last week against the los
angeles unified school district and the
board of education saying that a cotton
field was set up at an elementary school
in 2017 that was intended to teach
students about the experiences of slaves
reshunda pitts had a 14 year old
daughter who was referred to as sw in
the lawsuit experienced emotional
distress
as a result of the project at laurel
spann school that her social justice
teacher
said was to help students quote
gain a real life experience
as to what african american slaves had
endured
oh boy
the suit also names the school's then
principal
and social justice teachers defendants
since the project laurel spann school
was closed and a new school laurel
cinematic arts creative tech magnet
was created in its place
um
she said in september of 2017 her
daughter who used to vibrantly share her
day with her mother
became very quiet and reserved
um and you may
imagine this one day as pitts
was dropping off her daughter on campus
she saw a cotton field in front of the
school
and called the office to speak with the
school's principal amy diaz
who was
unavailable
pitt spoke with the assistant principal
who explained that her daughter's class
was reading frederick douglass's
autobiography and that the cotton field
was created so students could have a
quote real-life
experience of slavery
well
they had a whole big thing
this was right over in west hollywood
of course
of course it was
that a whole big uh thing
and uh so she didn't have to pick the
cod on her daughter
um but she had to watch other students
complete the project while she was
while she cared for other crops in the
garden i mean god
god god help us
so i like to say well we're teaching the
white kids about
what happened
uh
with slaves so they're gonna have to
pick the cotton but why don't you go
tend to some okra
or some other uh vegetables in the
garden
so they have to have
they are making a black girl ten two
vegetables in a garden
while watching white people do the
cotton thing and this is a good idea
this was someone's idea of a good idea
um
and now there's a lawsuit
and there's a lawsuit now
i don't know how much emotional distress
the daughter experienced i imagine it's
something
but
a jury will decide
but again it's one of those things where
i go
of all of the things
that
people sue over
if your daughter came to you and said i
uh your black daughter came to you and
said i uh
today at school they did a project where
we picked cotton
to learn about the experiences of slaves
i can imagine that you would be upset
about that
that would not go over
big
so there is a lawsuit and um
we don't know what will happen
we are
waiting here
with baited breath
we don't know
um
sad
they tried to change the name of the
school they tried to
but this is going to follow them it's
kind of
there's no getting around this
the problem with this is when people
when people start to use their
imagination
and they're trying to be good people
they tend to do the most horrific things
that have ever been done
this is not uncommon
when people are trying to be good people
and they don't know how to be
and they think they can
flip a switch
and understand something
or
be a quote part of the solution
uh on the right side of history
whatever it is um
and they start using their
imagination they start being creative
about how to do that
uh
the horror
is unending
it's uh terror
will be unleashed
they will do things
that they think are genuinely good
um
until
people see them and go what the [ __ ]
is this
i mean they will literally
i mean
the idea that they had a cotton
field
in front of the school
like they had to this was not an
accident
this was planned
it happened
with the full knowledge of many many
people
that had to sign off and go this is a
good idea let's get the kids out there
let's get them picking cotton
that then they'll understand what the
slaves went through
if they have to pick cotton
in front of the school
insane
but this is what happens when you have
people
that are going like how can we
creatively
show children what slavery was like
instead of worrying about
other things you go how can we let's put
our heads together
how can we recreate slavery today
for the kids
no no i know i know we got the math test
but
we want them to feel
the lashes on their back
and the calluses on their hands
we want to recreate
chattel slavery
today at school
how can we recreate settler
colonialism
after lunch
yeah that's a bad idea
this is a bad idea this is not a good
idea this is the opposite of that
but this is not surprising i know some
people that
would do something like this thinking
that it is good
you know
we built a gas chamber in the gymnasium
to teach the kids about
what do you mean you're upset
what are you upset about
how were they gonna know
what the holocaust was like if we didn't
build a gas chamber in the gymnasium
we wanted to give the kids yes well some
of the kids got to be little nazis
and then some of them got to be jewish
people it's
they're becoming better people
what is wrong
it's uh absurd but this is the
this is what happens
so
go get the money
make them cough up
some money i'm going to talk about uh
the condominium in la right now that's
on the market for 50 million dollars
don't you want to spend 50 million
dollars to own a condo in west
hollywood
google west hollywood and hit
news west
hollywood
okay okay
let's see here
first article member of rapper's
entourage shot
ends up in west hollywood before dying
at hospital
three sought in fatal shooting at gas
station near beverly center
a boy
west hollywood
is
a problem
you're not good
for crime
if you google west hollywood
crime
you can you can just read
some of the stories about things that
are
going on
that's not good
two weeks ago the crime has uh risen by
38
man shot near weho
gun owner thwart's home invasion
go to the sheriff's weekly crime report
okay
see what's going on
assault
grand theft grand theft residential
burglary strong strong armed robbery
strong armed robbery strong arm robbery
grand theft burglary
robbery vehicle burglary vehicle
burglary vehicle burglary other weapon
well
how about 50
million dollars
to live
in the penthouse
of a new building a new because in los
angeles now they're trying to introduce
this concept of vertical living
because people you know what's happening
los angeles has always been the home of
the single family house
with your yard and maybe your pool
and your dogs and kitties running around
and the husband tinkering with the car
and you're in the back uh you know
looking at the lemon tree or the orange
tree uh idyllic lovely yes
but now people are coming in the windows
they're climbing over the fences they're
hanging out in the yard maybe a bit of
rape they say who knows
and they're killing
so what they're trying to do is they're
introducing vertical living because
people say good news we'll make uh condo
buildings and we'll charge uh millions
and millions of dollars for these condos
and we'll put guards outside of them so
the people that want to rape and kill
you can't get in
and we'll put all of the things you'd
want all the finishes the bathrooms and
the kitchens and the marble and the wood
and the pine and the oak and the
travertine marble and this and that and
you get it all and it's all behind guard
gates guards and gates and guards and
gates and gates and guards and guards
and it's going to be like the uh the
castle from the wizard of oz with the
flying monkeys
uh and we'll have an army of flying
monkeys if anyone comes near us and
we'll have a moat and we'll have
alligators in the moat and if you have
the little key fob you can get in you
get right through the alligators say
well how do you do and they let you in
it's not a big deal 50 million is the
penthouse
apartment this article says a special
kind of crazy in la a 50 million condo
in the land of homeless tents
there's something funny about los
angeles the idea that it has the biggest
homeless population in the world and all
the hit shows about la are about real
estate
it's all about high-end real estate and
everybody uh is uh living in a uh you
know like a uh
cooler
everybody's living like a coleman cooler
and nobody is seeing any of the irony in
that in that it is the selling sunsets
and the million dollar listings and the
beverly there's just there's more shows
so many shows all about
the privilege of selling real estate or
buying it in los angeles california and
they're trying to sling
a 50 million
dollar condo in los angeles
wow
i mean big time
and
you can
from your condo that is 50 million
look
outside
and you will see
people
who are filthy dirty people
from head to toe soot
lesions
maybe they look like lepers
pushing
shopping carts
full of their belongings
in the hot summer
and maybe people like that that some
people might like that
that might be a benefit
but that is a potential view
from a 50 million condo in that area
you might
i mean imagine paying 50 million dollars
for a condo
and then outside you're staring and
you're just watching
society unravel
in front of you
interesting
get up the video of these realtors
talking when the
fire alarms are going off and the the
police are going off this is a very very
funny thing
a bunch of the top real estate agents in
los angeles california
are gathered together to talk about
how great it is to live in los angeles
and the the pride of it and the weather
how great it is
so here listen to this
for the summer for the year or whatever
i think a lot of new yorkers are coming
for the summer with the intention of
maybe staying but they all want to rent
first that's what i listen to the
background malibu is so crazy
you can just hear in the background we
have one friend
police sirens and fire trucks as the
city burns spending 180 000 on la costa
that's literally what it was 180 and
guess what he actually did get it was he
leased it
for two weeks for sixty thousand dollars
two weeks for success they have to
address the police sirens in a minute
you know you have to have a 31 day
rental in malibu
for those who are tuning in uh just now
uh you're with the real deal trd talks
live we're with some of la's top brokers
talking about the market and the changes
since kovada stephen let's let's zoom
out a little bit uh knight frank puts
out the bible well
here this one must have come out in
january february and they had you know
they rank they sort of rank la against
the other alpha cities new york london
miami et cetera uh investment lifestyle
except many other many tiers la was
sixth or seventh in sort of the running
compared to some of these cities what's
your what's your sort of unscientific
take on where it could be now
there's going to be reversal because if
you look at the cities above la that on
the night frank chart
they're all high-rise cities
and you have hong kong above l.a which
is the democracy everyone yeah but with
the political upheaval going on there
prices are going to go down and people
are going to leave they're not going to
give up their freedom
so los angeles because of horizontal
living and the incredible weather
i i was surprised to see
um livability that los angeles was down
in the 10 or 12. maybe traffic well
traffic but if you have to work and live
in a big city there's no place like los
angeles there's no snow
the air is
relatively clear now yeah traffic but
you end up living you wind up you wind
up living where traffic isn't
an impediment you're not driving from
covina to get to your office
city
so for us it's a police department i
listen to it you can hear them right now
right no less yeah so they're real
they're all mentally ill so they're all
see see they're all sick
and to to live here to do that job and
god bless them but they have to be ill
so they're sitting there telling
everybody what a great city it is and
how the weather is amazing and you can't
live anywhere else how could you live
anywhere else and in the background it
is the sounds of hell
just sirens
and fire trucks and cops
responding to you know i don't know some
woman who lit her children on fire or
you know two homeless people who are
eating each other in the street like
but they all got a smile and it's you
gotta keep it light keep it hey keep it
light
it's like a saturday night live sketch
if you know that was
a thing you would laugh at but
this is so funny you just gotta hey keep
it light
keep it like what about our what about
our police response time
and they know full they know full well
what's going on here they know full well
but i get it they can't
i mean
get that money
um
so i mean i'm just saying if you have 50
million dollars and you want to buy a
condo
there's no better place to do it right
now than in west hollywood california
uh it's a great investment of 50 million
dollars into a condominium so you can do
uh
stand-up comedy
if you so choose you can go and tell
people
what gets you going
what
is your problem
sheath underwear is the most comfortable
underwear that i've ever
had
what say you
same
absolutely
do you know the story of this
was just underwear what do you mean
the owner of sheath underwear was iraq
war veteran oh
and he started a company
called sheath underwear
because
he wanted something to do when he got
back
from
iraq
isn't that inspiring to you yeah that's
that's awesome
i mean to me
it's really cool
here's another thing that people don't
know about him and this is
he was the person who locked chelsea
manning in that cage
and he was very guilty about it
so he started an underwear company for
men
when he came back
kind of as a [ __ ] you to her
still
but he's the owner robert patton
and he locked chelsea manning in a cage
go to sheath underwear dot com and get
the most comfortable underwear you'll
ever wear
if you use the promo code tim20 you'll
also get 20
are you telling me they're giving 20 off
the order yeah
i mean it's
it seems too generous
that's http dot sheath underwear dot com
s-e-a-t-h
sheath
underwear dot com promo code tim20 for
20 off your order
the stretchy fabric is made of a
moisture wicking technology they're
super soft keep everything cool and
comfortable and right in place i mean
you couldn't go swimming in them they're
like swim trunks too
you know
and they had that dual pouch uh yes dual
pouches yeah it's a game changer it is a
game changer
i mean
it is great it's sheath underwear folks
everybody's using it and everyone loves
it and it's
you see the brand new materials they
have especially if you're a sensitive
guy
what are they doing
or they
bamboo and mesh brand new materials
well do you know for cooling do you know
how to use inspired to do that
they used to take prisoners of war over
there and they used to have to wrap them
in materials where they wouldn't die
so they could still breathe but they
would have
all their senses would be blacked out
should be like sensory blacking out as a
way to torture them but they couldn't
die so they had to let them breathe
so that's how he came up with these new
materials that's awesome because he was
like wait we called his old buddies and
goes what was that material we used to
wrap those people like mummies and leave
them out in 100 degrees sun
go to sheath underwear calm and get the
most comfortable ever underwear ever
use promo code tim20 you'll get 20 off
your order that's promo code tim20 20
off your order only underwear i own only
underwear you own correct
for all of your summer travels whether
you're going abroad or staying domestic
you want to immerse yourself in the
culture now is a perfect time to start
apple
we always talk about this bad
you're learning a language right now i
want to learn a language we all want to
get dual citizenship we all want places
outside of america we all want to travel
babel you need up to 10 minutes to
complete a lesson only 10 minutes and
you can start having like real life
conversations in a new language in as
little as three weeks this is amazing
you're actually using it right now
yeah i was learning swedish i'm
switching to spanish more practical yes
with babel you can choose from 14
different languages including spanish
french italian german plus babel's
speech recognition technology helps you
improve your pronunciation and accent
there are so many ways to learn with
babel in addition to lessons
you can easily access podcasts games
videos stories and even live classes
plus it comes with a 20-day money-back
guarantee start your new language
learning journey today with babel
i'm really excited about this because i
want to learn
a language
well yeah you're you but you already
signed up for it i'm learning a language
right now
and it's german
oh my wife's learning german spreckensie
deutsch
levidis
[Music]
right now save up to 60 percent off your
subscription when you go to babble.com
timberland am i reading that right
because that seems
crazy oh it might be a typo
hmm
oh no no that's it
that's what it is
apple.com for up to 60
percent 60 off your subscription yeah i
mean it's too good to be true
babble language for life
so this judge that sold a bunch of
children to
um
former judges who sent kids to jail for
kickbacks must pay more than 200 million
these are some evil [ __ ] they were
selling kids to jail to private prison
are those kids worth 200 million great
question
but u.s district judge christopher
o'connor awarded 106 million in
compensatory damages and 100 million in
punitive damages to nearly 300 people in
a long-running civil suit against the
judges writing the patents are quote the
tragic human casualties of a scandal of
epic proportion in what came to be known
as the kids for cash scandal
mark civerella and another judge michael
conahan shut down a country run
juvenile detention center and accepted
2.8 million in illegal payments from the
builder and co-owner of two for-profit
lock-ups
now if you remember any of this this was
the guys they were giving draconian
sentences very long sentences
two kids because this is where
uh they were making their money
civilia ordered children as young as
eight to detention many of them
first-time offenders deemed delinquent
for petty theft jaywalking jaywalking
truancy smoking on school grounds and
other minor infractions these guys
should be executed truly they should be
put to death and killed i mean this is
insane the judge often ordered youth he
had found delinquent to be immediately
shackled
handcuffed and taken away
without
giving them a chance to put up a defense
or even say goodbye to their families
should we have on the show a thing
called point for hassan [ __ ]
and should we have like a little thing
what is he what race is he uh i can look
it up let me see
is he a turkish
hassan is uh
is of turkish descent it says so should
we have a little turkish delight the
candy and when
something very bad happens in the
capitalist system because should we say
point for hassan [ __ ] we get we put the
little turkish light over there the
little cube the little cube don't you
like that isn't that a candy that you
like yeah you got me in australia yeah i
don't love it
but this is a point for uh him who did
he did like a 71 minute reaction uh
video to my joe rogan rant oh really i
think so i don't know who knows with
those people i mean it's you know
the guy streams 38 hours a day okay i
mean i i get i'd be doing it too
i'd be doing i'd be doing it too tim
dillon eats pancakes let's react to that
but what does it say about the
capitalist system
um it's unlikely that now adult victims
will even see a fraction of the
eye-popping damages award but a lawyer
for the plaintiff said it's reckoning a
recognition of the enormity of the
disgraced judge's crimes i mean the
judges this is the evil
of
[Music]
people that pervert this system you
should not have private for-profit
prisons it's a bad idea
now do they sponsor our show i don't
know
probably
but they're still not it's not a good
idea to have private prisons where
children as young as eight years old are
going there for jaywalking
isn't that crazy to you
of the 280 people to 79 were under the
age of 13. 79 of these kids were under
the age of 13. that's horrible
and they were sentenced to these crazy
long sentences right
how long
i mean it would vary but i mean enough
to really ruin your life look at this
several of the childhood victims were
part of the lawsuit when began in 2009
have since died from overdoses or
suicide
i mean
can we just for a minute
can we for a minute think about this
from the judge's perspective
i said for one minute not forever okay
kids are pieces of [ __ ]
no it's listen it's still
these judges are bad they should be uh
executed really
i mean
they're evil
this is evil
um
this is insane kids for cash judge
released from prison over virus concerns
yeah i missed this part of the article
cause of covid they let him do uh what's
it called
i don't know it's called uh this uh
released a home confinement with six
years left on his sentence because of
kovid
so he like what
someone i mean jesus what happened to
vigilante justice here
if that was my kid i would kill these i
would kill these judges
i'm not saying you should but i would
you know
some of these parents might have been
like take this kid and get it out of
here
i got
things to do
man evil behavior from these guys when
you're when you're talking about
and by the way this isn't okay
if people are older either i'm not
trying to do one of these things where i
go oh the guy's 25 you can sell them
this is a bad idea and in fact
[ __ ] schools
should start building private prisons
in the playgrounds to teach the kids
about confinement in a for-profit
institution
and if i was a teacher and i should be
we would have private prison
simulations all the time where kids
would be locked up
and we would explain to them why this
happened that seems like a good idea
and i'm for it
these judges are horrible and hopefully
they die
um
yeah i mean this is crazy
have you you know a lot of like people
like i know some people do i don't know
anyone that went to one of these private
prisons
as a kid i don't know anybody
my neighbor jill once put a pins
petition on me person in need of
supervision
and jill lived next to me
and my parents would sometimes be gone
and i was in the backyard with a friend
of mine and we were smoking pot and i
think we threatened her with a knife
but it was like a joke but we like waved
a knife around like we'll kill you
but it was like not you know what i mean
she called the police i got a pins
petition person in need of supervision
and i had to go to like family court to
get that lifted or get that removed so
that was like cps cps exactly child
protective services and they tried to
put a
pins petition on me and we had to go to
my uncle
and we went to court and we got that
removed and i said i've been doing the
right things and
you know
i'm a good person
but this is a
this is a real problem if you do not
have
a
family
that can help you
um and a judge like this sentences you
to a situation like this
you
will end up oding
or you will end up
uh
turning to drugs
and it's incredibly sad so these guys
are pieces of [ __ ]
um
point for hassan [ __ ]
the imaginary turkish delight we put it
there
we'll stack them up
who's what's the other side what was
there another side yeah when he's not
right oh okay and then that's also
turkish delight no that would have to be
in a like an ameri of food of my of my
heritage
like a potato
so if he's wrong about something we'll
put a potato on one side
of the scale mm-hmm i like that like a
big scoop of mashed potatoes it will
fulfill the descriptions
it was correct
i of course
you know i just this is an egregious
example of the horrors of the current
system i mean really
can you find and by the way i want to
talk about this
this new season of cobra kai is insane
what they're going to do okay no and i
didn't well you don't know that you
don't this is not okay i have inside
information here and i barely i barely
want to discuss this
because this is going to
enrage people and i don't want to be the
first one to talk about it cobra kai
is a show on netflix
about karate
right
it comes from the karate kid right yes
it's this it's in its fourth season it's
fourth season
on netflix it is a
uh what would you call this a reboot or
an extension it's a sequel to the
original karate it is this sequel to the
original karate kid films what they're
doing is they have these dojos these
warring
dojos
of uh these martial arts groups kids
they fight each other and they dislike
each other right
cobra kai and netflix
they're adding a dojo this is true of
all unhoused people
in los angeles homeless people who are
forced
to beat the [ __ ]
out of each other for food
and and the kids and the homeless people
fight each other
there's a third dojo this season and
it's all homeless people
in los angeles
and the kids go and [ __ ] them up
the kids are like grabbing their [ __ ]
chopping carts and threatened just beat
the [ __ ] out of them and then the
homeless people learn
karate
and they come back and they [ __ ] these
kids up the homeless people learn the
art because it's martial arts
they learn how to control themselves and
it is actually the pathway for many of
them to get housing
and to get sober
martial arts
and this is the whole idea is that
martial arts
is actually what needs to happen with
the homeless and then it is not
more funding or even more police or more
enforcement
literally it is martial arts
is what changes the
change is the thing for these homeless
people
and i just think that's
a little weird personally
that they would do this cobra kai and
netflix would do a whole
season
where you have a dojo of homeless people
being forced to beat the living [ __ ] out
of each other
i mean to me it feels
wrong
you know what it it feels tone deaf yes
to me personally
it
feels tone deaf
to me personally
they teach the homeless people many of
them who have like one of the one of the
new characters
is a guy with like iraq war flashbacks
okay and they teach him
how to quiet his mind
and michael arusso grabs him and goes
quiet your mind he's like you don't know
the things i've done in fallujah the
things i did for this game and he's like
quiet your mind
and beat the [ __ ] out of that kid
and now you have just homeless
homeless people learning karate
because that's
really and
you know in all seriousness
it's probably
the reason that many of them
are homeless is that they don't have
discipline
and actually
in cobra kai's defense
martial arts is like a great organizing
principle of how to like structure your
life
so like it's maybe not the worst idea
to
give homeless people free karate lessons
and let them join
the dojo
there are certainly worse ideas
that i've heard yeah especially for that
show i think
yeah that show took a [ __ ]
around season three yeah and it's over
now
it's all over
you know
the kids on stranger things like 38
years old
they're like divorced twice
you're going to bump into one of those
kids in l.a like three years seem like
i'm divorced bro
like finn wolford's gonna have like a
divorce yeah in like five years and he's
gonna be like sitting there
like drinking coffee in a cafe like
smoking cigarettes staring at the ground
and you're gonna be like hey what's
going on fan you're gonna be like hey
yeah what
what's going on he's like yeah i'm
[ __ ] divorced
and i can't work
because i'm 40 and i still look like a
freak
i'm kidding you know rosebud baker a
comedian just did some movie that he
directed oh really yeah i don't know
which one
i won't show it on screen i'm just
curious we're not trying to give these
people publicity they're doing enough on
their own really frankly you know who
who who helps me does anyone help me
by the way
is it does anyone help me
or do i have to keep pumping everyone
else
can anyone help me please
yeah his first feature film it's called
what's it called uh well i think that's
what he's uh
to write indirect new horror comedy film
it says here and so yeah why am i why am
i not in it
why am i not in it
am i not funny nice
am i not horrible
his directorial debut what's it about
uh let's see
oh uh uh
write and direct a new horror comment
it's called hell of a summer
uh
plot details and story lines are being
kept hush hush and it's unclear when the
film is slated what eaters what
why can't we know what it is
hell of a summer
is it about when we put my mother in a
home
these things always suck
horror comedies
always bad
yeah always think of one cabin in the
woods what else i was gonna say army of
darkness okay there's some things that
are sean of the dead
things like that oh yeah that's i love
that actually
but
what
we just keep daving
no no you're you're no you're right it's
like three
ends a fan of heart i'm a creator of it
we have very different
a very different opinion it's true we
have very different opinions on things
i am a creator of art ben is like a
fanboy
so we have different we have different
reactions but he did direct the netflix
special and by the way
i don't think people asked to understand
how difficult it is to direct a netflix
special because you stand up comedy
special because you have to point the
cameras at the stage
it is one of the hardest things that
anyone has ever done which is why every
member of ben's family has tagged him 95
times in the thing that says directed by
ben avery
because they're so proud of him
and they have a reason to be proud of
him
because
the people that shot the special work
for louis
c.k and joe rogan
this group of people so they were
incredibly new at this they were novices
they had only done what four specials
with joe and four with louie or
something
they had they hadn't done a lot
so ben made sure that they all
pointed the cameras in the direction of
the stage
and not
i don't know
the lobby of the theater or
someone
else how was it working with it what
were the what were the the real
challenges of the
oh the challenges of getting the cameras
out to face the stage well uh first of
all i was thwarted immediately because i
tried to leave all the lens caps on the
cameras when they were shooting because
i was actually trying to sabotage the
whole well but no let's think about it
your family's incredibly proud of you
about this
and
they're very proud
and
do they do they understand that they any
of them could have done this
like do your brothers and mother
understand that they too could have done
this uh thing that you did
should we say they are also executive
producers and by the way why is my fat
agent on that i did not know why is he
why special thanks to him
i think well he got me the meeting with
brady
so he set up a zoom meeting with brady
did he put himself did he put himself as
special thanks
because no one put him
oh no i think it's sam talent uh wendy
who runs con and i think it might be
justin i know it is but who put him
no i mean literally who put him
i have no idea a special thanks who put
him i don't know man i put sam talent
and wendy who put him once i got into
netflix's hands someone could have just
sent them a note
well was it me
well it's just a little bit absurd
and insane
that my agent
who sat there through the first show
that was unusable eating spaghetti or
whatever he was doing
uh has put himself
as a special thanks
you know who no one thanked me
everybody else got thanked the agent
you
but it was different it is difficult it
is not it's not an easy thing to do
to point cameras at a stage
it is very difficult
and i am very happy that ben did it as
well as he did it was it it was tough
and trying
but we appreciate that and we are very
very very grateful to him
a genius
of of a man
who was able to
point a camera
at me
for an hour
it's like this show
it's exactly well this show's more
difficult occasionally you look
something up
it's a little harder right
uh but it was you know that was that was
pretty big
ordering all of your summer essentials
with dash pass by doordash is a great
way to get everything you need during
the summer of dash pass you can save
money and access members only offers
that will help you feel easy breezy and
beautiful all summer long summer is in
full swing and the celebration begins
during the summer of dash pass by
doordash with meekly with weekly members
only benefits and new items released
every week you can shine bright and feel
cool
all season long do you order from
doordash but wish you didn't have to pay
delivery fees well dreams do come true
during the summer of dash pass you can
save money and enjoy
members only benefits every week on top
of zero percent delivery fees all year
round say hello to summer savings during
the summer of dash pass from doordash
say hello summer savings zero delivery
fees exclusive items we're gonna say it
again
more than 25 000 members only uh members
only offers nationwide
there's passed by doordash has
everything you need to make your summer
memorable
shine bright like during door dashes
summer
shine bright like a diamond
what do we do ben what are you telling
him about the code
oh so what's awesome about this what as
you get to well one you get to shine
bright during door dash's summer of dash
pass [ __ ] yeah that's that's not that's
shine bright like a diamond
on top of that you get 50 off your first
order up to 15 dollar value if you use
promo code tim dillon at checkout when
the sunshine's will shine together
that's 50 of your first order up to 15
value when you sign up for doordash
during summer dash using promo code tim
dillon
t-i-m-d-i-l-l-o-n don't forget put your
hands in the air
that's code tim dillon t-i-m-d-i-l look
like you just don't care for 50 off your
first order up to fifteen dollars it's a
party in the usa
dash pass benefits only on eligible
orders that meet the minimum subtotal
terms apply
sometimes
people are very
stressed out
do you understand that
oh yeah i can relate
and sometimes those people are
in the summer
oh yeah
and they're in the summer
and they're upset
and they're sweating
and they're like
why am i not happier
you understand that
yeah i mean well you got to take care of
your mind dude how
i mean
well can i ask you let me put it in like
the layman's terms real quick
how well would you take care of your car
if you had to keep the same one your
entire life
i don't think i would take care of it
well at all
well that's how our brains work so why
don't we treat them that way
if i had a car my entire life
probably beat the [ __ ] out of it
well
well you shouldn't treat your brain like
that because how we care for our minds
affects how we experience life why
because it's important to invest time
and care into keeping them healthy why
because there are plenty of ways to
support a healthy brain like learning a
new language or taking power naps why
there's also better help online therapy
oh
there you go
what is it
um
here's my thing
sometimes i want to stay home and get
therapy and not leave my house is that
what this is
yeah if you were already thinking about
inventing it it already exists and it's
very successful can i get someone on the
computer to listen to me [ __ ] and moan
yeah
oh yeah i don't have to leave my house
no
never what if i don't like this
therapist can i get a new one yes
when can i start communicating
well
it's an online therapy that offers video
phone and even like i imagine yeah i
imagine this would cost me around six
million dollars a year
uh let me see here
let's see oh our listeners get ten
percent off their first month at
betterhelp.comd
what
betterhlp.com
are you telling me
i'm asking you a question here
[ __ ]
you're telling me
can i talk about my experience with
therapy
okay
i was like really sad in college and um
i went to therapy a few times and i felt
like a lot better after but well you
shouldn't have
but my therapist was kind of eh
he wasn't my favorite and i wish i could
have got a new guy but i stopped going
but then you don't want to fire your guy
that's why you just want to do
everything over
with my therapist when i was younger i
went
because my parents were getting a
divorce
i think everyone should go to therapy
for sure
i think i think it's great i think you
should try if you never tried therapy
you should try it once it might be a
game changer
better hlp.com
it's much more affordable than in-person
therapy and you can be matched with a
therapist in under 48 hours
and not only this it could be a live
chat only therapy session so you don't
have to see anyone on camera if you
don't have to so go to some can i sing a
song about therapy yeah you do it
sometimes i feel
like i don't have a partner
sometimes i feel
like i don't my only friend
is the city i live in
city of angels
i joined better help
and got 10
off
wow that was beautiful i wrote that
i don't ever wanna feel
like i didn't use better help take me to
the place i love
the better help website
we're done
sugar bay
what
it's the [ __ ] chili peppers all right
you sick [ __ ]
andrew tate they've removed him i don't
know what's what why they're removing
him
they're just removing people now they
don't like it seems
yeah and they never give a clear cut
here they never give a reason i mean by
the way i've heard a lot of what he
has said and i know some of it gets
people going but
uh you know some of what he says that
i've heard
isn't that crazy
what is this misogyny is a hateful
ideology that is not tolerated on
tick-tock
what that's not true
um
yeah i just they seem like they're
removing people
with whom
they have
underlying ideological differences
and they're just trying to figure out
how to get rid of them
and again
i'm not
joining hustlers university i won't be
signing up
but i don't think you should this guy
should be uh removed
i i don't you know
what is like do they even tell anyone
why
well they just say you're misogynist but
then they don't like the the thing is
they don't link you to the specific
thing
wasn't even misogynist a month ago when
he was on too like this is what i don't
understand why wait what's changed
why can't a misogynist talk
i don't understand
he thinks let's say he thinks men are
better than women
let's say he has that belief
i mean i don't know it can should he not
be able to say anything
you know
i i'm just
i'm unmoved
people will counter his belief with
their own beliefs
some of them will be quite persuasive
you know
i just don't understand
why now it's like misogyny
is it grounds yeah and now we're getting
kicked off and apparently he's been
booted from twitter as of 2017 because
he tweeted now here's a specific one
right he tweeted that women who are
sexually assaulted bear some
responsibility
i don't know the context of that post
but or what made him think it but
i think if you look at his larger quote
his larger context
he said something to the extent if you
go out and get drunk and go home with a
guy and get into his bed and he does the
wrong thing
you have to analyze some of your
behavior now by the way you could be
offended by that it's absolutely
appropriate to be offended by that and
say i i think that he's justifying
or excusing uh uh rape
but
i also don't think by the way
that that is a crazy beyond the pale
opinion that is not held by lots of
people and what i mean by that is this
there are a lot of reasonable rational
people out there that think that yes men
are violent
certainly when you add alcohol to the
mix and they're strangers and it doesn't
justify their behavior at all
but the idea that a woman doesn't have
to take extra care to protect herself
in our society is probably
naive to believe that
so i don't
you know i i i again i just think that
like
they want a villain
and he may want to be the villain i
don't know i think they're casting him
in the role as the villain and maybe he
wants to be that role i don't know him
but if if i look at the the
examples i'm being given here
i'm not seeing anything sufficient to
remove this guy
from social media yeah
completely
i don't see any reason for that
and again no one's gonna care what i say
right
but i did just
speak on the joe rogan show and i said
the most um
i said the most meaningful thing that's
ever been said
on his show that that rant i had was the
most
articulate meaningful thing that's ever
been said in the history of the world
to be honest it was
do you believe there was anything that's
ever been said that's better than that
uh
sermon on the mount what's the sermon on
the map
i think it's uh
it's that one jesus did where he was
like
we should all like be nice to each other
and stuff yeah how'd that work out like
i'm like
like it's like i'm talking about [ __ ]
that's real
it's gonna actually happen
you're talking about fairy tales
um
yeah i just listen
i'm not saying that women are should be
blamed for rape i'm saying that
someone should be allowed to offer an
opinion on a controversial
situation
he's in one video he demonstrates how he
would attack a female partner if she
ever accuse him of cheating
quote it's bang out the machete boom in
her face and grip her by the neck shut
up [ __ ]
it's bang out the machete boom in the
face and grip her by the neck shut up
[ __ ]
um what's he doing there cutting her
head off
uh he's just describing uh how he would
attack a female partner if she ever uh
accused him of cheating and he goes it's
bang out the machete boom in her face
and grip her by the neck like you got to
threaten her she got it right up next to
her well but if my whole thing is if he
didn't cheat
and she's accusing him of cheating how's
he supposed to respond
i'm
i'm confused
um
maybe it's in maybe it's in a better
context here should we play this maybe
it'll make sense yes
okay
a man can only cheat if he loves someone
else if i have a woman who i truly love
and i go out and [ __ ] and i come back to
her and i don't care about her and i
only love my girl that's not cheating
that's exercise
if she even talks to her it's very funny
by the way that's incredibly funny yeah
it's not that bad
well
well you know listen man
people are gonna this is what's gonna
happen
um
the bigger you get the more of a target
you become and listen i'm not saying
andrew tate is
you know i don't think he should be
the go-to for i think young guys
listening to him probably
will get some bad ideas in their head
but this young people often have bad
ideas in their head and good ideas in
their head and they sort them out as
they get older this is not new
none of this is new i had bad ideas in
my head when i grew up and you know who
they were from my parents
you know now there's people on the
internet that can influence people for
sure
but there's a lot of other people that
can influence you too positively
negatively
i don't see any rule the ruling is
gavel put him back on social media
please i don't see any reason
holding a machete to someone's neck if
that's a problem well i don't know get
me out of here
you didn't do it he said it
yeah i'll put a machete to someone's i
mean that's hypothetically speaking he
would do such a thing if he said if
right
x then why
if i'm accused of cheating i'll use the
machete
but he's not really going to do it
it's probably a goof
it's a joke i don't know
there's there's got to be a villain all
the time
we're a society and you make a lot of
money being the villain by the way
people like villainizing you
and um
around time the uk police were
investigating abused hate is understood
to have left uk from romania in one
video explaining his reasons for the
movie suggested it was because it'd be
easier to evade rape charges
he goes this is quote for probably 40 of
the reason
i'm not a rapist but i like the idea of
just being able to do what i want i like
being free
well but does that mean he's raping
people
technically no
he's saying he likes the idea of having
it as an option because you could read
that two ways he goes listen i'm not a
rapist i like the idea of being able to
do what i want i like the idea
of doing that when i'm free so i think
there's a way to interpret that where
he's going listen i'm not like so sicko
i just don't want to be uh i don't want
to live in a nanny state
but i didn't know
you know what i mean like i think he's
then in april the brothers mansion was
raided by police following a tip-off
from the us embassy that a 20-year-old
21-year-old american woman was being
held against her will
tates were taken in for questioning
before being released and denying
wrongdoing the romanian authorities said
last week that the investigation
later expanded to cover human
trafficking and rape allegations was
ongoing
yeah i mean
i don't know about any of this he just
had a cam house where he would like
there was like cam girls and stuff
i mean what are you gonna do
i mean you know
my problem is when you take somebody off
social media they can't respond to any
of this right this is the big problem if
you destroy people's ability to respond
you can say stuff about them
and this is a gavin mcginnis point
actually that i'm making here
many years ago when i when i knew gavin
um who
he is also controversial
um
but
gavin
said yeah they kicked me off all these
things and i couldn't respond
so people could say anything about me
they could say i'm a nazi i'm this i'm
not
and i did not have any
place to respond to what was being said
about me so no matter what you think
about gavin that that is a
valid
argument that if you kick somebody off
and you call them names
maybe they're true maybe they're not but
that person now has no recourse
to talk back
and then you can kind of villainize them
[Music]
and create this character that they may
or may not have been
and this seems to be
the mo of a lot of these companies this
is what it seems to be it does not seem
to be
changing
and i do believe this ultimately
will lead to a
kind of a
schism
google schism and tell everyone what it
means
this is going to lead to a schism
it is a split or decision between
strongly opposed sections or parties
caused by differences in opinion or
beliefs that's correct but this is what
it means
what it means is that
i believe you're going to see i think
rumble's one of the first
attempts at this with a lot of
people on it you're going to just
further see
uh people
retreating into
their corners here you think you think
tate will go to rumble
i could he could be a rumble guy i could
see that yeah oh yeah for sure or uh
as a pickup artist guy those guys
usually have their own websites he could
go on like a pickup artist for him and
and probably destroy behind his own
paywall though right listen
i don't know what he's doing i'm sure
the courses he teaches are not
uh
going to lead you to be a billionaire
but i think when you just take somebody
off all of social media
uh it is you know there has to be some
there has to be
andrew tate's hustlers university
affiliate program shut down following
metaban
this guy got so big so quick yeah they
put a stop to that
yeah
and again i don't know much about him so
i mean it's very possible that he's not
a good guy but there's a lot of people
that aren't a good guy right
it's also possible he's misunderstood or
whatever and you know i don't i don't
care
you know whether people are good or bad
to me is such a boring and
it's like
it's like what is the greater what is
the what is the greater
threat this guy
or companies deciding whether or not you
can speak
it's like
is this a guy
this like
pick up artist guy with the
university
the biggest threat is he a bigger threat
then
the collusion of government and big tech
this big blob of power that's completely
unaccountable that can
shut you off at any time is that
not dangerous at all does that not merit
a discussion
and we're talking about our whether a
romanian guy got in a fight with his
girlfriend in 2017
because he's got he's hot on the
internet for three months
this is this is the thing
he must be vanquished now before what he
becomes the president
i'm i'm confused
as always
again
it's not defending you know
the the the forest for the trees which
is something that no one can see and
people choose not to
um
if fathers
cannot
cannot go back to talking to their sons
we're all doomed
doesn't matter if it's entertained or
whoever
if if people cannot
go back to educating their children
about how to act and behave
then i i don't know what hope there is
really
so this guy can be as kind of a
scapegoat and he's got some wacky ideas
but
at the end of the day
you know
i think it you know
you gotta look at really
what is the reason
for his popularity
what is the reason for the popularity of
a lot of people
is it because we do live in a world
where many manifestations of traditional
masculinity are kind of bemoaned and
demonized
and called toxic
and that
dudes are trying to figure out and
navigate
a new landscape
and sometimes it just feels good if
somebody goes hey [ __ ] it
[ __ ] it
i'm gonna say
egregious crazy [ __ ]
because
the new world
is exhausting
tiring
and there's nothing in it for you
they're building a world
where
if you're a straight white guy or any
straight guy really
um you're constantly told that you
inherently
your nature
is a
danger and a problem
and
there's somebody who comes along and
goes no it's not you're actually fine
you're okay and
that's popular well of course it's gonna
be pop why wouldn't it be popular
now yes does it go too far and does he
say crazy [ __ ] i'm sure it's the
internet
but well why is it why is it getting an
audience why is it
gaining traction because no one is
speaking to these young kids young men
young dudes they're
they're not being
served by anybody
speaking to them
groups of people that
are being championed
or being included in a discussion or
being praised
do not include a lot of these young
dudes
who have no idea
where they fit into society
so
it's the job of their fathers or the job
of their families communities but maybe
all that shit's not working right maybe
it's not happening
enter andrew tate enter whoever
and
you know some of what he said i think
that i've heard has been pretty good i
said stop whining figure
figure yourself
out there are ways that you can
be self-reliant
productive
you know this doesn't mean that these
are all
gonna work
but i do think some of it is positive
for sure
um and i've always had a problem when
everybody goes yeah we're just going to
delete
people and then everyone goes good and
then they
enjoy the deplatforming of their enemies
and then when it happens to them they
don't uh
they don't make the connection
they feel
they fail to make the
connection
yeah
but i don't know i would not
i don't know if i'd be buying his course
i don't really i don't know how many
people's course i would buy
what is his course at hustler's universe
is it like lesson one
how to choke a [ __ ] out with a machete
i don't know
it's supposed to be like helps you with
investing i'll but i'll join it if it's
about the machete
uh thanks for all the uh positive
feedback with uh ben's directorial debut
tyndalencomedy.com for any live dates if
we put them up
we have a merch drop when's that coming
you've handled that too when's that uh
coming
uh well didn't you say you want a movie
is your family gonna do that are they
gonna go congrats on the merch
ben and emailed the designer who did the
merch
you think we'll have like seven of those
things
congrats to
ben he did he emailed the merch guy
congrats yay
[Applause]
so when do you think that it comes out
like january
like
were you saying like october 1st
i would like it to come out in late
september october do you think that's
possible very possible yeah
ben's angry with me because we
we ended up recording the episode late
so he he harbors a lot of resentments
and rage he's a very rageful and angry
person
but that anger only destroys him it has
absolutely no impact on me
you understand no no it's not i'm a
sober person i don't have resentments
ben
white knuckles his sobriety and has
resentments and rage issues and anger
but i don't have those things nope
every every second you spend hating is
like stealing a precious jewel from
yourself
that's right you know what resentments
are it's hating someone while they're
out dancing
they're unaffected
so i'm unaffected by your hatred of me
i said you've been very hateful all day
you don't you don't feel like that i
thought i've been like funny and fun
you've been very sloth-like and hateful
[Music]
yes you've been very tired you've been
like spaced out and kind of out of it
and uh
you know
it's just the behavior
just the behavior it's not my
it's not my fault
it's not my fault
right
what's not your fault
you're going through
i don't think i'm growing going through
anything okay
i'm just i'm just uh
you're tired no i'm just i'm not even
tired i'm just chilling
i got i'll be up till
5. why will you be up till five get the
episode out
you're like the slaves on the plantation
outside of that school picking the
cotton
you want to sing an old slave song
together
oh uh how about
um
what's that one i don't know really low
voice
well that's not a slave song it's old
man river that's a slave song
no he's just on a he's on a he's on a
riverboat
but is he like i don't pick cotton oh
yeah he does say that
[Music]
yeah well anyway i didn't i you know
what is that yeah i guess it's true
do you have anything else to plug here
well can you get them excited about the
merch you keep downplaying the merch
you're like oh it won't be it's gonna be
good it'll be fine i came up with uh one
of the designs for it what is your
design that you came up with
the
cough one the alpha okay
okay
i chose the typeface and uh yeah
i came up with the giant for the knife
fight well don't tell him
don't tell surprise it's supposed to be
a surprise
no one's impossible
i came up with a fake business
you came up with the
enron logo in the app
but i came up with the actual fake
business but i i edited the podcast that
you did that went out that's correct
and i could have like the camera could
have been out of focus the whole time
maybe i could have forgot to hit record
that's right lost to the sands of time
that's right but you didn't do it i'm
sure you'll do that more and more often
as
you're
as you try to kill me
which is fine stop imitating joe so
wrong of you
[Music]
idiot
we're delusional
it's 103 a.m we've got three more hours
to go here
unless i put it out tomorrow at six
because i wonder if it'll mess us up in
the algorithm to put it out so early
when are you gonna put it out i'm
thinking maybe tomorrow at six since
it's so late if we put it out no one's
gonna be up no one's gonna be watching
it and then it's just gonna get yeah put
it out tomorrow at six yeah that makes
sense
oh i forgot it's saturday
yeah
what
can you play uncle fina doing the black
set
from yeah i just can't play the uh video
yeah yeah i'll just do the audio
and do the audio yeah yeah
oh there's like compilations over doing
this
oh that's amazing black scent
compilation
yeah i just won't play uh
we just leave with this because i think
it's funny okay and i don't know why
anyone's mad at it and i actually think
it's i like this
i think it's fun
[Music]
sorry about danny
this is the ocean aids recruitment scene
oh i gotta slide through this now
[Music]
she came back though she like she like
oh here we go
free card monty okay
follow the queen live your dream but
don't sleep don't sleep because she
might disappear by that
i like it that's crazy to me
she likes you all right that's it and
we're following them she said let's hit
it n-word
i like it it's our only choice i think
it's good
i think it's fun
not by the way is that andrew tate's
fault
is that andrew tate's fault
is there a way to blame that on andrew
tate too
tim dillon comedy if you uh tim trey
dillon di lloyd on instagram twitter
real hero netflix special thank you we
will see you soon good night goodbye